Mexican drug lord Joaquin el chapo
guzman has been extradited here to the
United States where he is to face
several drug trafficking charges now I
mention this because while El Chapo's
awaiting trial we've worked out a deal
with federal law enforcement agencies
and well ladies and gentlemen sitting in
on drums please welcome El Chapo
[Applause]
I'm curious how long have you
how long have you played the drums El
Chapo oh geez she say I started about
five ten minutes ago it's it's great to
have you here I'll trap oh isn't it
great Andy well I guess I mean he's a
very dangerous man
come on Andy he seems like a real nice
guy to me oh my god he's escaped
[Applause]
sorry sorry I just grabbed back by this
in and out okay
favorite burger hmm I'm saying el chavo
why did you burrow a tunnel to go to in
and out
old habits die hard Conan I'm a
borrowing kind of guy you got a good
drummer el chapo Hey
I must buy the drums as I am as good at
making tunnels okay okay I like going
looked at that one drum like it was
sneaking up yeah that wasn't even a joke
El Chapo hey careful Conan I could cut
off your head and put it on a tortoise
[Music]
you're sounding a little Russian now El
Chapo
Hey here he goes
[Applause]
[Music]
began it I don't know what where he's
back yes sorry I just have to get his
straw okay
all right really not worth it go trim
there hey we got a great show tonight El
Chapo star of the Hulu series the path
he's beloved Aaron Paul's on the side
he's great I love breaking bad you know
because of the drug stuff you you would
like Breaking Bad hey author of the book
life of the party comedian Bert
Kreischer you're an idiot and musical
guest colony house is on the show their
basic stole my girlfriend
that's not I've been this is a bad Oh No
you
[Music]
[Applause]
you